so speaking of bubbles buying the top
and and kind of nothing changing you
know you have a historian type view of
financial markets over a very long
period centuries of time and I tend to
agree with you that different players
same game if you apply that to
cryptocurrency Bitcoin digital assets I
think that many people would argue we're
actually seeing different players same
game on steroids no question about that
and so you know my disclaimer is what I
know about crypto Patrick o Shaughnessy
my son taught me and and literally he
taught me in a Wichita hotel lobby while
we were waiting for the golf bus to come
and I looked out of my way all right
Patrick you know because he's doing his
whole hash power yep thing and which I
thought turned out really well
but I go ok I'm five years old explain
it to me and so I have I let's put it
this way I have just enough knowledge to
be dangerous and so and so I always go
into my standard here is something
financial people never say enough I
don't know okay I don't know and if
we're gonna use that as our jumping-off
point I'm happy to talk about it but
listeners I don't know I don't know
sometimes the three yeah it gets it
across absolutely I mean look I think
that the beauty and why I want to talk
to you right was there is some ignorant
sin bliss or are there some bliss and
ignorance right around the asset almost
doesn't matter know right and and look I
I've always said that the four horsemen
of the investment apocalypse are fear
greed hope and ignorance if you think
about that only ignorance is not an
emotion fear greed and hope have wiped
out more fortunes than anything
historically in auction-based markets
and you know look the last edge in my
opinion is to arbitrage human behavior
why markets change minute by minute
human being and human nature changes
imperceptibly millennium by millennium
there's your edge mm-hmm right because
even though people are gonna say oh
we'll never do that we would never ever
ever do that they say that right up
until the minute they do it so you were
kind of looking for you know where have
we seen this movie but what what and I
think just just to clarify right so the
asset is highly liquid global you know
it's all the stuff but the bubble right
or the correction that we just saw over
let's say the last 12 months I think is
a a pattern especially when you
literally look at it on a chart that is
very very reminiscent in almost an exact
overlay of many markets previously oh
definitely
in the fourth edition of what works on
Wall Street we had two charts in there
one was the South Sea Bubble that Isaac
Newton lost a fortune in and the other
one was the Nasdaq and they're identical
basically really and you know we the the
the time that I remember that is so
reminiscent of what we're seeing now a
little a little of the edges off though
because the corrections been pretty
significant generally speaking when the
corrections get to be this significant
people are feeling real pain and so the
ambulance and the enthusiasm definitely
wanes like rothschild you saying wait
until there's blood in the streets to
buy but going in to the dot-com boom so
this I wrote a paper called the internet
contrary in' which I can send you if
you're interested in April of 1999
basically outlining why I was about as
bearish about any trend during my career
and I said when this ends and it's gonna
end badly the number of books that get
written about that by the by authors
it's just going to end so badly because
ultimately economics matters mm-hmm and
and then what did I do
I founded an Internet company
not too smart this way uh so it was a
company called net folio it was the
first robo-advisor in 2000 and the the
valuation extremes were I mean it was
crazy it was literally crazy and what
what happens here's the guy who's
talking about you've got to have rules
governing your emotions you cannot get
excited about this it's gonna ruin you
it's gonna ruin you mm-hmm
getting a good idea which I think it was
a good idea for a robo-advisor you could
it's not like the current robos it
actually lets you trade without a cost
and you could build your portfolio we
would show you a bunch of back tests on
portfolios and you could go from very
conservative very aggressive
anti-smoking Kick Philip Morris out the
next name on the list comes up so it was
a pretty slick environment and offering
and of course the ultimate internet
crash came when a guy by the name of
Jack Willoughby who I I know he's he's a
very interesting guy who writes for
Barron's
and very smart but sometimes a little
like Colombo in other words he's so
smart he tries to kind of convince you
that he's not but you can see it it's
those are the ones to watch out for
definitely and so he kind of thought he
was musing with this editor and he goes
I wonder how much cash
all of these internet companies have
yeah and what they're burn rate is yeah
well it would seem to me that if they
can't raise more money that these are
all their death dates yep and they're
like do it right the story now the
story's name you can find it online I'll
send you a bunch of these links but they
changed the name from burn rate to
something else burning money or whatever
but that story literally took the
internet down because it was like
everyone collectively woke up at exactly
the same time and went oh my God we're
all gonna die you know and boom and and
that was kind of it
it was the end all the VCS we had VCS
wanna throw
huge valuations at us disappeared mm-hmm
and and you know the the number of
careers that got ruined in that I once
debated a guy on stage because we always
come at investing kind of from a value
perspective yep
although we do use momentum and other
things so we're not you know and in
quality and we have a very kind of
complicated sauce now but he was on
stage in Minneapolis with me
big crowd and his and it was a debate
and his advice to the people in the
audience was only by technology
companies and especially Internet
companies that was it and I kind of
looked at him I said I'm sure I heard
you wrong you didn't just say to by not
only just one sector but a specific
component of that sector and he goes he
goes the the the economy has radically
changed forever it is never going back
to bricks and mortar and you know I was
39 at the time he's saying Jim you know
you're you're a bit of an old codger for
someone who's only 39 years old and I
said but but math and things didn't go
well it's a we like to say the pesky
facts facts